hi there let me take the pleasure of
welcome you to this as your tutorial I'm
Sam and as your cloud architect walking
for simply lon and I'm more than glad to
walk you through the session where we're
gonna talk about as you're in great
length and fret and if you're looking
for a video that talks and walks you
through all the services in Azure then
this could be one of the best video you
could find in the Internet and without
any further delay let's get started
everybody likes story is it so let's get
started with a story in a city not so
far away as CEO had plans to expand his
company globally and called one of his
ID personnel for an IT opinion and this
guy has been in the company for a long
time and is very seasoned with the
company's infra and he nicely answered
the questions with what he foresaw and
he said I have a good news and a bad
news for us to go global and he starts
with the good news he said sir we're
well on our way to become one of the
world's largest shipping company and the
bad news is however our data centers
have almost run out of space and setting
up new ones around the world would be
too expensive and very time-consuming
now the IT personnel let's call him Mike
now he explains the situation from how
he saw it but the CEO had done some
homework
about how he was going to do it and he
answered Mike saying don't worry about
that Mike I've come up with a solution
for a problem and it's called Microsoft
Azure well Mike is an hardworking and
honest IT professional working for that
company but he did not spend time on
learning the latest technologies and he
asked his question very honestly oh how
does it solve a problem and the CEO
begins to explain Azure to Mike and he
starts with what is cloud computing and
then he goes on and talks about Azure
and the service is offered by Azure and
why Azure is better than the other cloud
providers and what are the great
companies that uses
sure and how they got benefited out of
it and then he winds it all up with the
use cases of I sure so he begins his
explanation saying Microsoft Azure is
known as the cloud service provider and
it works on the basis of cloud computing
now Microsoft Azure is formally known as
Windows Azure and it's Microsoft's
public cloud computing platform it also
provides a range of cloud services
including some of them are compute
analytic storage and networking we can
always pick and choose from these
services to develop and scale our
applications or even plan on running
existing applications in the public
cloud Microsoft Azure is both a platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service
let's not fit their conversation out and
let's talk about what a cloud computing
as your services offered by as your how
is as your leading when compared to
other cloud service providers and what
are the companies that are using Azure
let's talk about that in simple terms
cloud computing is being able to access
compute services like servers storage
database networking software analytics
intelligence and lot more over the
Internet which is the cloud with the
flexibility after resources that we use
like anytime I wanted results I can use
one and it becomes available immediately
and any time one at a time and the zoe's
I can simply retire a torsos and not pay
for it and we also typically pay only
for these services that we use and this
helps greatly with our operating cost to
run our infrastructure more efficiently
and scale our environment up or down
depending on the business needs and
changes and all the servers and storages
and databases and networking all that
are accessed through the network of
remote systems or remote computers
hosted in the Internet to be
in the providers data center which is
Azure in this case now we don't use any
physical server or an on-premises server
here well we still use physical servers
and VMs in a hosted on a hardware or a
physical server but they're all in the
providers environment and none of them
sit on premises or in our datacenter we
only access them remotely it looks and
feels the same except for the fact that
they are in a remote location we access
them remotely do all the work remotely
and when we're done we can shut it down
and not pay for them so some of the use
cases some of the use cases of cloud
computing are creating applications and
services the other use cases are storing
or using cloud for storage alone if
there is one thing that ever grows in
your organization is the storage every
new day there is a new storage
requirement and it's very dynamic it's
very hard to predict and if we go out
and buy a big storage capacity up front
until we use the storage capacity fully
the empty storage is you know we're
wasting money on them so instead I can
go for a storage with scales dynamically
that's in the cloud what storage or put
data in the club and pay only for what
you're storing and for the next month if
you have deleted or flushed out some
files or data pay less for it so it's a
very dynamic storage in the cloud and a
lot of companies are getting benefited
from storing data in the cloud because
of its dynamic in nature and the cost
that comes along with it the cheap cost
that comes along with it and also they
give lot of the providers like the shore
they give data application for free they
promise an SLA along with the data we
store in the cloud so there's an SLA
attached to it and they also provide
data recoveries as well if in case
something goes wrong with the physical
disk where our data is stored as your
automatically makes our data available
from the redundant or other places where
it had stored our data because of the
SLA they wanted to keep the other use
case for Azure is hosting websites and
running blogs using the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music Azure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of CDN content
delivery network which allows us to
stream a video or audio files with great
speed you know with that with Azure our
audio or video application works
seamlessly because they are provided to
the client with very low latency and
that improves the customer experience
for our application as your computer
service is a good place for delivering
software on demand there are a lot of
software's embedded software's that we
can buy using Azure and everything on a
pay-as-you-go service model so anytime
we need a software we can go out and
immediately buy the software for the
next one art or to our let's say and use
them and then return it back we're not
bound to any yearly licensing cost by
that as you're computing Services has
analytic available for us with which we
can analyze get a good visualization of
what's going on in a network beat logs
be the performance be the metrics you
know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over the heaps and heaps of logs
that we have saved as your analytic
services helps us to get a good visual
of what's going on in the network where
have we dropped where have we increased
or what's causing what's the major
driver what does the top ten errors that
we get in the server in the application
stuff like that those can be easily
gathered from the azure analytic
services
now cloud is really a very cool term for
the internet a good analogy would be
looking back anytime we look at a
diagram when we do not know how things
are transferred we simply draw a cloud
right for example and mail gets sent
from a person in one country to a person
in the other country the lot of things
happening in between from the time we
hit the send button and the time the
other person hits the real button right
and we let the simple and the easiest
way are for putting it in a picture is
simply draw a cloud and on the one end
one person will be sending the email and
on the other end the other person will
be reading the email so a cloud is a
really cool term for the internet now
that's some basics about cloud computing
now that we have understood about cloud
computing in general let's talk about
Microsoft Azure as a cloud service now
Microsoft Azure is a set of cloud
services to build manage and deploy
applications on a network with the help
of Microsoft as yours frameworks now
Microsoft Azure is a computing service
created by Microsoft basically for
building testing deploying and managing
applications and services through a
global network of Microsoft managed data
centers now Microsoft Azure provides SAS
which is software as a service and Pass
which is platform as a service and IAS
infrastructure as a service and they
support many different programming
languages tools and framework and those
tools and framework include both
Microsoft specific and third-party
software now let me pick and talk about
a specific service for example
management as your automation provides a
way for us to automate the manual
long-running and frequently repeated
tasks that are commonly performed tasks
both in cloud and enterprise environment
it saves us a lot of time and increases
the reliability and it kind of gives a
good administrative control and
can use the task automatically to be
performed on a regular basis to give you
a quick history of Microsoft Azure it
was launched on 1st February 2010 and it
was awarded or it was called an industry
leader for infrastructure and platform
as a service by a garnett now Gartner is
the world's leading research and
advisory company this Microsoft Azure
supports a number of programming
languages like C sharp Java and Python
all these cool services we get to use
and pay only for how much we use for
example if we use for an R we only get
to pay for an R even the costliest
system available and if you use them for
an R we only pay for that particular R
and then we got no more billing on the
resource that we have used Microsoft
Azure has spread itself more than 50
regions around the world so it's quite
easy for us to pick a region and start
provisioning and running our
applications probably from day one
because the infrastructure and the tools
and technologies needed to run our
application are already available all
that we have to do is come at the chord
in that particular region or build an
application or launch it in that
particular region and they become live
studying day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide low latency services to our
customers all right instead of in
traditional data center let's say you
know customers will have to or their the
quest will have to travel all the way
around the globe to reach a data center
which lives in the other side of the
planet and this adds more latency to it
and it is really not feasible to build a
data center near each customer location
because of the cost involved but with
Azure
it's possible Azure already has data
centers around the world and all that we
have to do is just pick the data center
building
and Raman there they're available
starting day one number one and also the
cost is considerably saved because we
are using a public cloud instead of and
physical infrastructure to serve those
customers from a very local occasion and
these services that azure is offering is
ever-increasing as of now as we speak we
have like 200 plus services offered and
they span through different domain or
different platform of different
technologies available within the as
your console portal now we're going to
talk about that later in this section so
hold your breath till we talk about it
but for now just know that we have like
200 plus services offered by Azure
let's not talk about different services
and assure starting with artificial
intelligence bless machine learning
where we have a lot of tools and
technologies so the wide variety of
services available on Azure includes
artificial intelligence plus machine
learning plus analytic services to get
and or to give us a good visual of how
the data or how the application is
performing or the type of for the
category of data stored and to read from
the logs and variety of compute services
different VMs with different size and
different operating systems different
containers available different type of
databases available a lot of developer
tools that are available for us an
identity service to manage our users in
the azure cloud and those users can be
integrated or federated with let's say
Google Facebook or LinkedIn so there are
some external Federation services they
can be used to integrate with our
identity system IOT is IOT services IOT
tools and technologies available and
management tools to manage the users
know creating identity is one and then
managing them on top of it is an a
totally different thing and we have
tools technologies to manage the users
cool services
for a data migration data migration is
now made simple tools and technologies
available for mobile application
development and I can plan my own
network in the cloud with the networking
services I can implement my own security
both as your provided and third-party
security services on Azure cloud that's
now possible and a lot of storage
options available in the cloud so these
are just a glimpse of the big list of
services available in Azure cloud so
that was a glimpse of what's available
in the cloud let's talk about the
services in a specific let's take
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones the azure
compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that Azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on-demand
we can also containerize our application
we have the option of choosing windows
or linux via machine and take the
advantage of the flexible options as
your provides for us to migrate our VMs
to Azure and lot more and these computer
services also include a full-fledged
identity solution meaning integration
with Active Directory in the cloud Oran
on-premises and lot more let's look at
some of the services that this compute
domain provides some of the services the
compute domain provides our virtual
machines and this as your virtual
machines gives us the ability to develop
and manage a virtual computer
environment or a virtualized environment
inside as yours cloud environment that -
in a virtual private network now we will
talk about Virtual Private Network at a
later point but as of now just I know
that there are a lot of services
available and as your compute service
that we can get benefitted
we could always choose from a very wide
range of computer options for example
you know we have an option to choose the
operating system we have the option to
choose whether the system should be in
on-premises or in the cloud or do we
want to maintain the environment both in
on-premises and in the cloud we have the
option of choosing the operating system
whether we want to use our own operating
system with some software attached to it
or do we want to go and buy the
operating system from the cloud from as
your marketplace and these are just a
few of the options available for us when
we want to buy the compute environment
and these computer environments are
easily scalable meaning we can easily
scale our VM instances from one instance
to thousands of virtual machines in a
matter of minutes or simply put in a
couple of button clicks and all these
services are available on a pair for
what we use model meaning there is no
upfront cost we use the service and then
pay for the services that we have used
as no literal long term commitment when
it comes to using virtual machines in
the cloud and these most of the services
are built on a pay per minute billing
basis all right and at no point because
of the pay per minute billing model at
no point we will be overpaying for any
of the services that's that's attractive
isn't it now let's talk about bad
service
now that service is always independent
regardless of whether you choose Windows
or Linux it's gonna run fairly well and
with bad service we can take advantage
of the environments unique features and
not only that in short the batch service
helps us to manage the whole batch
environment and also it helps to
schedule the jobs now this is your batch
services actually runs on a large scale
parallel and high performance computing
because of that batch jobs are highly
efficient in Azure and when we run batch
services this as your batch creates
pool of computer nodes and installs the
needed applications that we want to run
and then it schedules jobs to those
individual nodes in those pools as a
customer there is no need for us to
install a cluster or there is no need
for us to install a software that
actually could use the jobs or even to
manage or even to scale those
infrastructure are the software because
everything is managed by Azure and this
batch service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for I mean the
only charges that will be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and the storage that we will be
using of course and then it working
services that we will be using for this
batch of service
let's summarize this bad service we have
a choice of operating system that we can
pick and use and it scales by itself now
the alternative for the batch would be
queues but in cubes will have to pre
provision and pay for the infrastructure
even if we're not using it but with a
batch we only pay for what we use and
this batch service helps us to manage
the application manage the scheduling as
a whole as if they are just one thing as
next thing in the compute domain let's
talk about this fabric service now this
fabric service is actually a distributed
system platform that helps us to package
deploy and manage a scalable and a very
reliable micro service and containers
and what does it help this as your
fabric service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and lifecycle management to
applications that are composed of micro
services no infrastructure management at
all and with service fabric we can
easily scale
the application to tens or hundreds or
even to thousands of machines here
machines represent containers as next
thing in computer man let's talk about
virtual machines scale set now this
virtual machines scale said it lets us
to create a group of identical
load-balanced Wiens I just want to
mention it again
it helps us to manage a group identical
and load-balanced OPM's the number of
instances or the number of VM instances
in and in a scale set can increase or
decrease in response to the demand or in
response to a schedule that we define
you know the resources needed on a
Monday morning is not the same as that
would be required on a Saturday or a
Sunday morning all right and even within
the day the resources that would be
needed in the beginning of the business
hour is not the resources that would be
needed now at noon or you know after
8:00 or 9:00 in the evening so the
demands could actually vary in the
environment and this skill set helps us
to take care of the varying demand or
take care of the different
infrastructure requirement at a
different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the skill set also allows us to provide
high availability to our applications
and it helps us to centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
VMs as are they they are just one thing
now you might ask well what well
machines are enough why would we need a
virtual machine skill set just like I
said this virtual machine skill set
helps us with a greater redundancy and
improve performance for our applications
and those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes the requests to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set it helps
us to create a large number of identical
virtual machines number one and with
scale set we can increase or decrease
the virtual machines with virtual
machines scale said we can centrally
manage and configure and update a big
group of VMs and it's a great use case
when it comes to big data our container
workloads as next thing in compute
domain
let's talk about cloud services now this
is your cloud service is actually a
platform as a service and it's very
friendly in fact it is designed for
applications that support scalability or
an application that requires scalability
or reliability and and on top of it you
want them to be very inexpensive to
operate so as your cloud service
provides all these so where would this
cloud services run well it runs on a VM
but it's a platform as-a-service
VMS are infrastructure as a service and
when we run applications on VM through
cloud service it becomes platform as a
service so here is out you got to be
thinking with infrastructure as a
service like VMs we first create and
configure the environment and then we
run applications on top of it
let's look at the responsibility the
responsibility for us in VM is that we
manage everything and to end like you
know deploying new patches picking the
versions of the operating system and
making sure they are intact and all that
stuff it's all managed by us but on the
contrary with platform as a service it's
I mean it's as if the environment is
already ready all that you have to do is
deploy your application in it and manage
the platform
I mean manage the platform not as an
administrator because all the
administration is taken care by as
you're like now deploying new versions
of the operating system it's all handled
by the US Europe so we deploy the
application and we manage the
application that's it infrastructure
management is handled by as your so what
does cloud service provide this cloud
service provides a platform where we can
write the application code and we don't
have to worry about Hardware simply hand
over the code and cloud service takes
care of it so nobody on the hardware at
all
so responsibilities like patching what
do we do if something crashes how do I
update the infrastructure how do I
manage the maintenance or the downtime
in the underlying infrastructure all
that is handled by Azure
it also provides an good testing
environment for us you know we can
simply run the cord test it before it's
actually released to the production
I want to expand a bit on these testing
applications so this are your cloud
service it actually gives us an staging
environment for testing a new release
without it affecting the existing
release which actually reduces the
customer downtime so we can run the
application tested and any time that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging environment where
we can add more to it and then swap it
back at a later point so it kind of
gives us in swappable environment for
testing or applications and not only
that it gives us health monitoring
alerts it helps us to monitor the health
and availability of our application and
there is a dashboard we can benefit from
when we use Azure cloud services and
that shows the key statistics all in one
place and we can also set up real time
alerts to one when a service
availability or a certain metrics that
we are concerned about degrades as next
thing in computer domain let's talk
about functions now functions are server
less computing that many time if you
heard about as your being several less a
lot of time they are referencing or the
person who's talking to you is
referencing to server less computing or
as your functions which is a several
less computing service hosted on
Microsoft Azure
the main motive of a function is to
accelerate and simplify application and
development functions helps us to run
code on demand without we need to pre
provision or manage any as your
infrastructure so as your functions our
script or a piece of code that gets run
in response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running that code and the
best of all the best is when we use
functions we only pay for that time that
our code runs so what has functions
provide or what is
your functions provide as your functions
allow users to build applications using
soulless simple functions with a
programming language of our choice so
the current programming languages that
are supported is C sharp F sharp nodes
is the Java and PHP so here we really
don't have to worry about provisioning
or maintaining servers if a code
requires more resource yes as your
functions handles or it provides the
additional resources needed by the court
and the best part is we only pay for the
amount of time the functions are running
not the resources but the amount of time
the function is running as next thing
and moving to the new domain let's talk
about the container domain in as Europe
now the container domain or the
container service it allows us to
quickly deploy a production ready queue
manatees or a docker swamp cluster now
what's a container a container is a
standard unit of software that packages
of court and all its dependencies so the
applications run quickly and reliably
from one computing environment to
another it could be a testing to staging
to developing development environment to
staging to production or from one
production to another production or on
premises to cloud or one cloud to
another cloud vice-versa now imagine we
had an option not to worry about the VM
and just focus on the application well
that's exactly what containers helps us
achieve so these container instances
enable us to focus on applications and
not worrying about managing VMs or not
worrying about lowering the new tools
required to manage the VMS or even the
deployment and our applications that we
create they run in a container running
in a container is what helps us to
achieve all these not being able to
manage or not needing to manage the
virtual machines so these containers
they can be deployed into the cloud
using a single command if you're using
command-line interface and a couple of
button clicks if we are using the azure
portal and these containers are kept
lightweight but they are equally sick
you're as virtual machines let's talk
about container service as next thing
the container service or sometimes
called as as your Cuban it is service it
helps us to manage the containers
container is one thing and a service
that's used to manage the container is
another thing
now this cuba net is service or acs it
helps us to manage the containers so
let's expand on this a bit so this is
your container service or acs it it
actually provides a way to simplify the
creation configuration and management of
a cluster of virtual machines that are
pre-configured to run containerized
applications on top of them and
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take fifteen to twenty minutes and once
they are provision we can actually
manage them by using simple SSH tunnel
into them and this acs when it runs
application it runs applications from
docker images what does that mean a
docker images makes sure that the
applications the container runs are
fully portable images are portable and
ACS also helps us to ask orchestrate the
container environment not only that it
also helps us to ensure that these
applications that we run in containers
can be scaled to thousands or even tens
of thousands of containers so in a
nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using IKS or ACS is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that a
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is made simple using this container
services and even training of model
using a large data set in a complex and
resource intensive environment this a
case helps us to simplify that
environment all right as next thing in a
container domain let's talk about
container registry we spoke about
registry a little bit when we spoke
about docker images so container
registry is a single place where we can
store our images which are darker images
when we use when we use containers it's
it's darker images that we use for our
image purposes so these container images
are a central registry that can be used
to ease container development by easing
the storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kind of
images like docker swamp or the images
used in docker swarm rnq vanities
everything can be stored in container
registry in Azure
now anytime we store a container image
it provides us an option for geo
replication what that means is that we
can efficiently manage a single registry
replicated across multiple regions now
these geo replication it actually
enables us to manage global deployments
assuming we are having an environment
that requires a global deployment so it
helps us to manage global deployments as
one entity because we are geo
replicating we would be updating we
would be editing one image and that
image gets replicated throughout the
global replication centers we would have
set up and so just one editing would
have actually edited the global images
and those global images would have
provisioned at the global application so
one edit replication and then
provisioning of the applications global
wide and this replication also helps us
to helps us network the latency because
you know anytime an application needs to
deploy it does not have to rely on a
single source which which can be reached
only through high latency network
because we have global replications
around the world any time the
application wants to check back it will
check back the application which is in a
very nearby location for the application
itself
global replication means that we are
managing it as a single entity that's
being replicated across the multiple
regions in the globe as next thing in a
learning let's talk about as your
databases
now this Azure databases
a rational in fact they have many
flavours in them we're gonna look at
different flavors or sequel no sequel
cache type of database that as your
offer so we're gonna learn a one at a
time or are we going to learn one by one
so this is your SQL database is a
rational database in fact it's a
relational database as a service it's
managed by your we don't get to do a lot
of management in it so it's a rational
database as a service based on Microsoft
SQL Server database engine and this
database is a high performance database
it is very reliable and it's very secure
as well and this high reliability high
performance and for this high security
we really don't have to do anything it
comes along with it and it's managed by
your and there are two things that I
definitely need to mention about as your
SQL database that is it's an intelligent
service number one it's fully managed by
Azure and it also has this one good
thing which is it has built-in
intelligence that learns app patterns
and adapts to maximize performance and
reliability and data protection of the
application that's something that's not
found in many of the other cloud
providers that I'm aware of
so I thought I'll mention it so it uses
built-in intelligence to learn about the
users database patterns and helps
improve performance and protection and
migration or importing data is very easy
when it comes to Azure SQL database so
it can be readily or immediately are
used for analytic reporting and
intelligent applications in Azure as
next thing let's talk about as your
cosmo DB now as your cosmo DB is a
database service that is for no sequel
type and it's it's created to provide
low latency and an application that
skills dynamically or that scales
rapidly now this as your cosmo DB is and
a globally distributed service and it's
a multi model database this can be
provisioned in a click of a button
that's all we got
if we need to provision and as your
Cosmo DB in the azure it helps with
scaling the database now we can
elastically an independently scale
throughput and storage across this
database and in any of the azure
geographic regions it provides a good
throughput it provides good latency it
provides a good availability and it
provides or as your promises at a
comprehensive SLA that no other database
can offer that's the best part about
Kozma DB so this Kozma DB was built with
global distribution in mind and it's
built with the horizontal scale in mind
and all this we can use by only paying
for what we have used and remember the
difference between as your Kozma DB and
SQL database is that as your Kozma DB
supports no sequel whereas SQL doesn't
alright few other things about as your
Kozma DB is it allows users to use key
value graph a column family and document
data it also gives users a number of AP
options like SQL JavaScript MongoDB N
and few others that you might want to
check at the document at the time of
reading and the best part here is that
all that we mentioned we get to use only
by paying for the amount of storage and
throughput that are required and the
storage and the throughput can be
elastically scaled based on the
requirement of that art all right let's
talk about that is cache discussion
about Azure database won't be complete
without we talking about credits cash
now Redis cache is a secure data cache
it's also called it's also sometimes
called as messaging broker that provides
high throughput and low latency access
to data for the applications now let's
cache is based on and a popular open
source caching product which is Redis
sometimes called as that is cache now
what's the use case it's typically used
to cache to improve the performance and
scalability of system that rely heavily
on back-end data stores now performance
when we use that as cache is improved by
temporarily copying the frequently
accessed data to a fast storage located
very close to the APNIC
now with Redis cash this fast storage is
located in memory with Redis cash
instead of being loaded from the actual
disk in the database itself now this
Redis cache can also be used as an
in-memory data structure store not only
that it can be used as and distributed
non-relational database and a message
broker so there are variety of use cases
for this various cache and by using
various cache the application
performance is improved by taking
advantage of the low latency and the
high throughput performance that this
Redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this Redis cache when we use
Redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference
now this various cache is actually
backed by Redis server and it supports a
string hashes linked lists and various
other data structures now let's talk
about security and identity or services
now identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principle identities you might ask
now what's a principle identity now
identity or principle identity are
services applications users groups and a
lot more the speciality about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in cloud
it also helps authenticate and authorize
principles or resources on premises
especially when you run and hybrid cloud
environment so all these services and
features that this identity management
helps us to get additional level of
validation alike Identity Management can
provide multi-factor authentication it
can provide access policies based on
condition a permit or deny based on
condition it can also monitor suspicious
activity and not only that it can also
report it it can also help generate
alerts for potential security issues and
in a way to mitigate it can send us an
alert so we can get involved and prevent
and a security accident from happening
so let's talk more about Identity
Management so some of the services under
security and identity management are as
your security center now this as your
security center provides security
management and a threat protection
across the workloads in both cloud and
in the hybrid environment it helps
control user access and application
control to stop any malicious activity
if present it helps us to find and fix
vulnerabilities before they can be even
exploited it integrates very well with
analytic methods that helps us to
identify or it gives us the intelligent
to identify or detect attacks and
prevent them before it can actually
happen and it also works seamlessly with
hybrid environments so you don't have to
have one policy for on-premises and one
policy for the cloud it's now a unified
service both for on-premises and the
cloud the next service in security and
identity would be key walled now a key
Walt is a service or a feature that
helped safeguard the cryptographic keys
and any other secrets used by the cloud
applications and the services in other
words this as your key Walt is a tool
for securely storing and accessing the
secrets of the environment I mean the
secret keys now a secret is anything
that you really want to have a very
tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if I tell you what key
will actually solves that would actually
explain what key wall is now key Walters
used in secrets management it's helped
in securely storing the tokens the
passwords the certificates it helps in
key management and it really helps in
create
and controlling the encryption keys that
we would use to encrypt data it helps in
certificate management talking about
certification management it helps us to
easily provision manage and deploy
public and private SSL TLS certificates
in Azure and lot more so in a nutshell
this kewal it provides users the ability
to provision new walls and keys in just
a matter of minutes all that in a single
command or all that in a couple of
button clicks it also helps users to
centrally manage their keys secrets and
policies next in the list let's talk
about Azure Active Directory now Azure
Active Directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities but what does that mean
now this as your Active Directory is a
cloud-based Active Directory and
Identity Management Service now Azure
Active Directory combines and it's
actually a combination of the core
directory services plus application
access management plus identity
protection and one good thing about this
as you're in fact there are a lot of
good things but especially when you're
running hybrid environments you might
wonder well how this Azure Active
Directory is gonna behave
now this Azure Active Directory is build
to work on on-premises and cloud
environment as well not only that it
also works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well so in a nutshell
this is your Active Directory it acts as
an central point of identity and access
management for our cloud environment it
also provides good security solutions
that protect against unauthorized access
of our app and the data now that we have
discussed about security and identity
let's talk about the management tools
that azure has to offer
Azure provides built-in management and
account governance tools that helps
administrators and developers that helps
them to keep the resources secure and
very compliant and again it helps both
in on-premises and in the cloud
environment and these management tools
help us to monitor the infrastructure
monitor the applications it also helps
in provisioning and configuring
resources it also helps in updating apps
it helps in analyzing threats taking
backup of the resources built disaster
recoveries it also helps in applying
policies and conditions to automate our
environment we use Azure management
tools and it also used in cost control
methods so this as your management plays
a wide roll across the azure services
and in the management tools first comes
the as your advisor now this as your
adviser it acts as a guide to educate us
about as your best practices it draws
recommendations that we can select on
the basis of the category of service and
it also provides the impact it can have
or the impact that would happen in our
environment if we follow the
recommendations given and
recommendations or first one is the
recommendations are kind of templatized
and it throws the templatized
recommendations not only that it also
provides customized recommendations on
the basis of the configuration on the
basis of our usage patterns and these
recommendations are not hearts it's not
like something that it recommends and
then just leaves us hanging there and
these recommendations provided are very
easy to follow very easy to implement
and see results you can think of as your
advisor as an a very personalized cloud
consultant that helps you to follow best
practices to optimize our deployments it
kind of analyzes our resources our
configurations our usage and then it
recommends a solution for us that really
helps in improving the
cost-effectiveness improving the
performance improving high availability
and improving security in our as your
environment so with this as you're at
vizor we can get a proactive actionable
and personalized best practice
recommendations now you don't have to be
an expert just follow the usual adviser
and your environment is gonna be good
it also helps and improve the
performance security high availability
of our environment and also it helps in
bringing down the overall as you're
spent and the best part is it's a free
service that analyzes our as your usage
and provides recommendations how we can
optimize our as your resource to reduce
cost and reduce cost at the same time
boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment next in the list would be
network watcher now this network watcher
helps users identify and gain insights
in the overall network performance and
the health of the overall environment
now these are your Watchers provides
enough tools to monitor to diagnose to
view the metrics and to enable or
disable logs which means that are
generate and collect the logs for
resources in the Azure virtual network
so with network watcher can monitor and
diagnose issues in networking without
even logging into the virtual machines
with just the logs which are real-time
we can actually come to a conclusion
what could be wrong in a certain
resource in a VM or on a database and
over just looking at the logs and not
only that it's used for analytic or to
gain some intelligence of what's
happening in our network we can I gain a
lot of insight to the current network
traffic pattern using the security group
of flow logs that this network watcher
offers it also helps in investigating
VPN connectivity issues using detailed
logs now you might or might not know
that you know VPN troubleshooting
requires both parties or it involves two
parties another person the network
administrator on this side and the
network administrator on the other side
and they will have to check logs in
their end and we'll have to check logs
and our end
stuff like that but with the network
watcher it kind of takes it to the next
level
the logs itself we could easily identify
which side is having the issue and
suggest an appropriate fix and the next
in the list would be Microsoft Azure
portal now this Microsoft Azure portal
it provides a single unified console to
perform various number of activities
like building not only building managing
and monitoring the web applications that
we build
now this portal can be used to organize
our environment or the appearance of the
environment or the visual of the
environment based on our work style and
using Azure portal users can control who
gets to manage or access the resources
all from the air show portal and this
ishow portal gives a very good
visibility on the spends that happen on
each resource right and if we can
customize it we can also identify spins
based on team spends based on days
spends based on department stuff like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual of where the money is spending or
where as the bill consumed within the
azure environment next in the list would
be as your a resource manager now as
your resource manager enables us to
manage the usage of the application
resources now we use resource manager to
deploy monitor and manage solution
resources as a group as if it's one
single entity
now the infrastructure of our
application is typically made of various
components which includes virtual
machine storage virtual network web app
database servers some other third-party
services that we might use in our
environment and they are by nature
separate services but with as your
resource manager we don't see them as
different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports an
application no we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them
Fred as your resource manager identified
the relation between them and helps us
to visually see them all as one or
single entity not only that as your
resource manager helps or it ensures
that the resources that we provision are
deployed at a constant rate along with
the other application
it also helps users to visually see
their resources and how they are
connected and that helps in managing the
resources lot better resource group also
is used to control who can access the
resources within the users organization
kind of gives you the fine-grained
control over who gets to access and who
does not get access and the last one in
the management tools would be automation
and this automation gives us the ability
to automate configure and install
upgrades across hybrid environments it
provides a cloud-based automation and
configuration service not only that this
can be applied for non Azure
environments as well which is
on-premises so some of the automation we
could do is process automation update
management automation configuration
features automation stuff like that and
this is your automation provides
complete control during the deployment
operation and also during the
decommissioning of the workloads and
resources with automation we can
actually automate a time-consuming or
mundane or any task that's error-prone
because of human errors those things can
be automated so irrespective of how many
times you run it it's gonna run the same
way and that really helps in reducing
the overall time and also the overhead
cost because a lot of the things are
automated which means it's human error
free which means the application is not
going to break and keep running for a
longer time with automation we can
actually build a good inventory of
operating system resources and
configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue
says something happened because we have
automation because it's logging the
configuration changes it's easy to track
easy to identify easy to identify what
has changed lately that has broken the
environment go back and fix it or kind
of roll it back that solves the problem
and that actually summarizes the as your
management tools or management services
now let's talk about the networking
tools or the networking services
available in Azure there are variety of
services especially networking services
that as your offers and I'm sure it's
gonna be an interesting one let's begin
our discussion with content delivery
network now the content delivery network
in short CDN it allows us to perform
secure and a very reliable content
delivery not only that it also helps in
accelerating the delivery time or in
other words reducing the delivery time
also called as load times it also helps
him saving bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application let's
expand on this the content delivery
network is actually a distributed
network of servers that can efficiently
deliver web content to users now Syrians
are we gonna use the word CDN here
Syrians store cached content on global
edge servers also called as pops point
of presence locations that are very
close to the end users so the latency is
minimized it's like taking a copy of the
data or taking multiple copy of the data
and storing it in different parts of the
world and whoever is requesting it the
data gets delivered to them from a
server which is very locally to them
so this Syrian offers developers a
global solution for rapidly delivering
high bandwidth content to users by
caching the content in a strategically
placed location which is very near to
them so these content delivery networks
it really helps in handling that's one
advantage you get for content delivery
network that's we can handle spikes and
heavy loads
very efficient
and we can also run analytic against the
logs that gets generated in content
delivery network which helps in gaining
good insight on the workflow and what
would be the future business need for
that application and this just like a
lot of other services this is on a
pay-as-you-go type so you use the
resource first and then you only pay for
what you have used the next one in
networking would be Express route now
Express route is actually a circuit or a
link that provides an a direct private
connection to Azure and because it's
direct it gives low latency link to
Azure it gives good speed and
reliability for the azure data transfer
it could be on-premises to Azure so it
gives very good speed
it gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit anothers Express route is
an service that actually provides an
private connection in between Microsoft
data center and infrastructure in our
premises or in a different colocation
facility that we might have now these
Express routes do not go over the public
internet and because they don't go over
the public internet they offer a high
security reliability and speed and low
latency compared to the connections
which are in the internet because it's
fast because it's reliable because it
has low latency it can be used as an
extension of our existing data center
you know users are not gonna feel the
difference whether they are accessing
services from an on-premises or in the
cloud environment because the latency is
minimized as much as possible users are
really not gonna see the difference and
because it's a private line and not an
public internet line it can be used to
build hybrid applications without
compromising a privacy or the
performance
now these virtual private cloud these
Express routes can be used for taking
backups if assume
going through the internet that would be
a nightmare if you use Express route for
backups that's going to be fast and
imagine recovering a data through the
internet from the cloud through the
Internet to the on-premises in a time of
disaster that would be the worst
nightmare
so these Express routes can be used not
only to backup but also to recover the
data because it provides good speed low
latency recovering the data is gonna be
lot sooner
the next product or service we're gonna
discuss in networking is Azure DNS
now as your DNS allows us to host domain
name in Azure and these domain names
come with an exceptional performance and
availability now as your DNS is used to
set up and manage DNS zones and records
for our domain name in the cloud now
this as you DNS is a service for DNS
just like the name says and it provides
name resolution by using as yours
infrastructure and by using this domain
we can actually manage the DNS ourselves
through the azure portal with the same
credential imagine having a DNS provider
which does not even belong in RIT
imagine that environment you know we
would have a separate portal to manage
the DNS environment now those are gone
and now we can actually manage the DNS
in the very same Azure portal where we
use the rest of the other services and
this as your DNS very much integrates
with other DNS service providers it uses
a global network of name servers to
provide fast response to DNS queries and
these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because most
of the servers are maintained by a
Microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps resyncing let's say a server fails
it kind of helps resyncing with the rest
of the servers so all the Microsoft's
environment all the Microsoft's and
global
nameservers kind of ensures that our
domain names are resolved properly not
only properly but also are available
most of the time right next in the list
in networking services is virtual
network I'm sure this is gonna be very
interesting and I'm sure you're gonna
like it
so this networking or watchful
networking in Azure it actually allows
us to set up our own private cloud in
the public cloud it gives us an isolated
and highly secure environment for our
application let's expand on this then
this Azure virtual network helps us to
provision as your virtual machines and
it helps us to securely communicate with
other on-premises and Internet networks
it also helps in controlling the traffic
that flows through or flows in and out
of this virtual network to other virtual
networks and to the Internet
now this Azure a virtual network
sometimes called as v-net is actually a
representation of our own network in the
cloud it's actually a logical isolation
of the azure cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provision in a v-net that is separate
from another customers winners that way
we have that logical separation there so
this virtual network can also be used to
protein or VPNs in the cloud so we can
connect the cloud and the on-premises
infrastructure and lot more especially
in a environment where we have hybrid
environment surely we will be using what
you'll network because that's going to
require a VPN for secure data transfer
in and out of the cloud and in and out
of the on-premises environment all right
so it kind of gives us an boundary for
all the resources so all the traffic
between the azure resources they kind of
logically stay in between or logically
stay within the as your virtual network
and here we can design the network is
given over to us you know you can pick
the IP you can pick the routing you can
pick the sub
and a lot of freedom is given or I would
say a lot of control on how the network
is design it's not like something that's
already cooked and we only get to use it
now we can actually build the network
from the scratch we can pick the IP
address that we like we can pick you
know which subnet needs to communicate
with the other subnet stuff like that
and like I said if you are using hybrid
environment you definitely would be
requiring a virtual network because it
helps connect the on-premises and the
cloud in a secure fashion using VPN the
last product we're gonna discuss in
networking is a load balancer this load
balancer actually provides application a
good availability and a good network
performance so how does it work
it actually works by load balancing the
traffic to one from the virtual machine
and the cloud resources not only that it
also load balances between cloud and
across premises virtual networks with as
your load balancer we can actually scale
our application and create high
availability for our services which
means our obligation will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is gonna experience
downtown what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the TCP and UDP
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the backend full of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains high availability so
what does load balancer help a person
creation of high available scalable
in the cloud in minutes it can be used
to automatically scale the environment
with the increasing application traffic
and one feature of load balancer is to
check the health of the users
application instance and it removes or
it stops sending the request to the
unhealthy instance and kind of shifts
that connection to the healthy instance
that way a user or a connection does not
get stuck with an instance that's not
healthy that's all that you need to know
about the networking services now let's
talk about the storage services are a
storage domain in Azure now as your
storage in general is a Microsoft
managed service providing cloud storage
which basically is highly available
secure durable scalable and redundant
because it's all managed by we don't get
to manage a lot of it and these are you
storages are a group of storage services
they capture different needs and the
storage products include as your blobs
which is actually an object storage it
includes as your data Lake it includes
as your files as you see it and it
includes as your queues it includes as
your tables and lot more but let's start
our discussion with as your store simple
as your store simple is an hybrid cloud
storage solution that actually lowers
the cost of storage to nearly 60 percent
of how much you'd be actually spending
without using it so as your simple
storage our store simple is an
integrated storage solution that manages
the storage tasks between on premises
and the cloud storage what I really like
about Azure is that it's built around
the hybrid environment in mind there are
a lot of other cloud providers that are
there we're running an hybrid
environment is a big challenge you know
it has some compatibility you won't be
able to find and hybrid or on premises
and cloud solution for you need stuff
like that but with Azure especially when
it comes to storage a lot of the things
that we're gonna see it clearly
is designed with hybrid environment in
mind all right so let's come back and
talk about store simple so store simple
is an very
efficient cost-effective and a very
easily manageable SAN storage area
networking solution in the cloud at are
all throw in disinformation the reason
why it God store simple is really
because it uses store simple 8000 series
devices which are used in as your data
center and this store simple or simple
storage it comes along with storage
tiering
to manage the stored data across the
various storage media so the current the
very current data is actually stored in
on-premises on solid-state drives and
data that is used less frequently is
stored in HD DS or hard disk drives and
the data that requires archived or that
needs to be archived very old data let's
say less frequently use data candidate
for archive they are actually pushed to
the cloud so you see how this storage
tiering automatically happens in store
simple and one another cool feature of
store simple is that it enables us to
create an on-demand and scheduled
backups of data and and then store the
data locally or in the cloud and these
backups are actually taken in the form
of incremental snapshot which means that
they can be created and restored quickly
it's not a complete backup it's an
incremental backup and these cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important when there is a disaster and
when there is a disaster recovery
scenario because these snapshots can be
called in and they can be put on storage
systems and then they become the actual
data so recurring is faster if you have
proper scheduled backups or if you have
frequent backups and this storage simple
it really helps in easing our backup
mechanism which means it kind of eases
our disaster recovery steps or
procedures as well so this store simple
it can be used to automate data
management data migration data movement
they're occurring across the enterprise
both in cloud and on-premises it
actually improves the compliance and
accelerates the disaster recovery for
our environment and if there is one
thing that's increasing every new day in
our environment that will be storage and
this is store simple at
that need and we really don't have to
pre-plan or think in deep or having a
proper storage because now we have a
simple storage available in the cloud
and moreover it's on a pay-as-you-go
type so not much pre-planning on storage
is needed yes there will be need but not
as much as I would without the cloud or
without the simple storage and the next
service under storage that we would like
to discuss is the data Lake store this
data Lake store or storage it's a cost
effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this is data Lake storage is an
enterprise-wide
repository for big data analytic
workload that's the major service that's
dependent on this data Lake store and
this data Lake enables us to capture
data of any size of any type and of any
ingestion speed and it kind of collects
them in one single space or in one
single place for operational efficiency
I mean operational efficiency and for
analogy purpose Hadoop in Azure is very
dependent on this data Lake storage and
this data Lake store is designed with
performance for analytics in mind so
anytime you think of or anytime you're
using analytic in the cloud or anytime
you're using Hadoop in the cloud in
Azure we are definitely using or we will
be to the most part or the normal
procedure or the right storage to pick
would be data Lake store in Azure its
design with security in mind so any time
we use Azure storage we can be rest
assured that we are using storage from
within a data center which has or which
was built with security in mind so this
data store also uses Azure blob storage
behind the scenes for global scale
durability and for performance let's
talk about blob storage a blob storage
provides large amount of storage and
scalability now this blob storage is the
object storage solution for Azure cloud
let's expand a bit on blob storage I
should
Bob storage is Microsoft offering for
object storage now this blob storage is
optimized for storing massive amount of
unstructured data which could be text or
binary data it's designed and it's
optimized for rapid reads if I explained
to you on what scenarios we would be
using lob storage that might help you
get a good understanding of what blob
storage is so it's help or its design as
of now it's being used in many IT
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
accident a lot of effectors can fetch
data from Azure blob storage and it
currently helping users stream video and
audio it's currently being used for
writing log files it's currently being
used to store data as backup and restore
at a later point in terms of disaster
recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud IT
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
store in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates and data a new version
gets created which means at any point
again rollback as in when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the users storage need it
also supports tearing of the data so
based on need when I actually explore I
would find lot of options I can pick
from that you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like I said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest-based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be a queue storage now queue
storage provides durable queues for
large volume
cloud services it's a very simple and a
cost effective durable messaging queue
for large workers let's expand the
skew storage or for a moment now this Q
storage is a service for storing large
amount of messages that can be accessed
from anywhere in the world through HTTP
and HTTPS calls a single queue or a
single cube message can be up to like 24
KB in size and a single queue can
contain millions of such 24 KB in size
messages and how much can it hold it can
hold up to the total capacity of the
storage account itself so that's kind of
easy to translate how much would it hold
and this as your queue storage it
provides an messaging solution between
applications and components in the cloud
what does it help it helps in designing
an application for scale it helps in
decoupling in the application so you
know it's not very dependent or
sometimes it's not at all dependent on
the other application because now we
have a queue in between which kind of
translates or which kind of connects or
which kind of decouples both the
environment now we have a queue in
between both the environment can scale
up or scale down independently the next
in the storage service would be file
storage let's talk about file storage
now these as your files provide secure
simple and managed cloud file shares now
with file share in the cloud it actually
extends the user servers on-premises
performance and capacity and lot of
familiar tools for the cloud file share
management can be used along with the
file storage that we're talking about so
let's expand a bit on file or storage
now this are your files or as your file
storage offers a fully managed file
shares in the cloud that can be accessed
we are the SMB protocol server message
block protocol now this as your file
shares can be mounted concurrently by
cloud or in on-premises deployments lot
of operating systems are comparable with
it windows are compatible Linux is
compatible Mac OS is compatible in an
addition to all these being able to run
on on-premises and on the
or being able to access from on-premises
and on the cloud it can also offer cache
for caching at the data and keeping it
locally so it's immediately available
when needed so that's some additional
feature I would say that some advanced
feature that it offers compared to the
other file shares available in the
market let's talk about table storage
let's talk about table storage now table
storage is a no sequel key value pair
storage for quick deployments with large
semi structured data sets the difference
between one important thing to note with
the table storage is that it has a
flexible data schema and also it's
highly available let's expand a bit on
table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less a no sequel type
table storage is the one we'll end up
picking it provides an key pair
attribute storage with a schema less
designing this table storage is very
fast and very cost effective for many of
the applications and for the same amount
of data it's lot cheaper when you
compare it with the traditional sequel
data or data storage so some of the
things that we can store in the table
storage are of course they're gonna be
flexible data sheets such as user data
for web application address books device
information and other types of metadata
for our service requirements and it can
have any number of tables up to the
capacity limit of the storage account
now this is not possible with sequel
this is only possible with no sequel
especially with table storage in a show
explanation of storage really concluded
the length and breadth of the
explanation this CEO was giving his IT
personal but this id personal is not
done with it yet he still has a question
even after this lengthy discussion and
his question was well there are a lot of
other cloud providers available
what made you specifically choose as
your I mean from the kind of question
that he asked we can say that he is very
curious and he definitely had asked and
very
thoughtful questions so his CEO went on
and started to explain about the other
capabilities of Azure or how it kind of
outruns the rest of the cloud providers
so he started or he again started his
discussion but from different angle now
so he started to explain what are the
capabilities or how Azure is better than
the competitors so he started with
explaining the platform as a service
capabilities and I'm gonna tell you what
the CEO told his IT person so this
platform as a service or in platform as
a service the infrastructure management
is completely taken care by Microsoft
allowing users to focus completely on
the innovation no more infrastructure
management responsibilities go and focus
on innovation that's that's a fancy way
of saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and as your especially is darknet
friendly as your supports the dot in a
programming language and it has or it is
built or designed or it is optimized to
work with old and the new applications
deployed using dotnet programming
frameworks so if your application is a
darknet most of the time you would end
up picking as your I mean if you try to
compare most of the time you would end
up picking as your as your cloud service
provider and the security offerings that
Azure offers is it's designed based on
the security development lifecycle which
is an industry-leading assurance process
when we buy services from Azure it
assures that the environment is designed
based on security a development
lifecycle and like I mentioned many
times in the past and I would like to
mention it again
Azure has well thought about the hybrid
environments which a lot of other cloud
providers have failed so it's very easy
to setup an hybrid environment to
migrate the data or not migrate the data
and still run a hybrid environment they
work seamlessly
with Asher because as you provide
seamless connection across on-premises
data centers and the public cloud it
also has a very gentle learning curve if
you look at the documentation its
picture rich and the documentation czar
neat and clear would really it would
encourage you to learn more it would
encourage you to think and imagine and
try easily get a grasp of how services
work so it has a very gentle learning
curve as your allows the utilization of
technologies that several business have
used for years so there is a big history
behind it it has a very gentle learning
curve that the certifications the
documentation at the stage-by-stage
certification levels it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing in other cloud service providers
now this would really impress their CTO
czar or people working in finance and
budgeting if an organization is already
using Microsoft software they can
definitely go and avail or be bold and
ask for a discount that can reduce the
overall as you're spending in other
words overall uprising of the Azure so
that's what helped or they are the
information that helped the CEO pick
Azure as his cloud service provider and
then the CEO goes on and talks about the
different companies that are currently
using Azure and they are definitely
using Azure for a reason like Pixar
Boeing Sampson easyJet Xerox BMW 3m they
are major multinational multi-billion
companies they rely run operate their IT
in Azure and this CEO has a thought that
his IT person is still not very
convinced unless and until he shows him
a visual of how easy things are in Azure
so he goes on and explains about a
practical application of Azure which is
what exactly I'm going to show you as
well all right a quick project on
building and as your app using or
building a dotnet application in as your
web app and making it connect to an SQL
database will solidify all the knowledge
that we have
gained so far so this is what we're
gonna do I have an azure account open as
you see logged in and everything is
fresh here let me go to a resource group
there's nothing in there it's it's kind
of fresh all right I'm logged in and
this is what we're gonna do so we're
gonna create an application like this
which is nothing but an to do
application to do list application which
is gonna run from the web app get
information from us and save it in the
database that's connected to it so you
can already see it's a two-tier
application web and DB all right so let
me go back to my Azure account the first
thing is to create and resource group
let's give it an a meaningful name let's
call it as you're simply long right and
it's gonna be a free trial and the
location pick one that's nearest to you
or you know wherever you want to launch
your application now for this use case
I'm gonna pick a central US and create
it's gonna take a while to get created
they go it's created it's called as your
simply learn now what do we need we need
an web app and an a separate SQL
database let's first get our web app
running so go to app services and then
click on add it's not the web app plus
SQL that we want we want web app alone
for this example so let's create an web
app give it a quick name let's call it
as your simply learn the subscription is
free trial and I'm gonna use my existing
resource group a resource group that we
created some time back it's gonna run
out of windows and we're gonna publish
the code offset we can create it alright
while this is running let me create my
database
right SQL database create a database
give it a name let's call it as you're
simply lon
DB put it in our existing resource group
that we created it's gonna be a blank
database right and it's gonna require
some settings like the name of the
server and the admin login the password
that goes along and in which location
this is gonna be created the server name
is gonna be as you're simply learn they
meet that's the server name and the
admin login can be what can be the admin
login name let's see so let's call it
simply lot that's my admin login name
and let me pick a password
click on create' so what have you done
so far we have created an web app and we
have created an a database in the
resource group that we have created so
if I go to resource group it's gonna
take some time before things show up so
if I go to my resource group I only have
one resource group as if now as you're
simply long and there I have a bunch of
resources being created and it still
being created right in the meantime I
have my application right here that's
running out of or that's in Visual
Studio as of now right so once the
infrastructure is set and ready in the
azure console how are we going to go
back to visual studio feed these inputs
in the visual studio so the code knows
what the database is the the credentials
to log into the database is stuff like
that so we're gonna feed those
information in visual studio by that
we're actually feeding it into the
application and then are we gonna run it
from there
deploying this application takes quite a
while we really got to be patient right
now we have all the resources that we
need for the application to run here is
my database and here is my apps service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is create an firewall exception
rule so one more thing needed is to
create an firewall exception rule right
so the application is gonna run from my
local desktop and it's gonna connect to
the database right so let's add an
exception rule by simply adding the
client IP it's gonna pick my IP the IP
of the laptop I'm using as if now and
it's going to create an exception to
access the database so that's done now
we can go back to our visual studio I
already have a couple of
apps running or a couple of
configurations pushed from a visual
studio I'm gonna clean that up if you're
doing it for the first time you may not
need to do this
all right so let's start from the
scratch this is very similar to how you
would be doing in your environment
alright so we're gonna select an
existing as your app service now before
that I have logged in as you can see I
have logged in with my credential so
it's gonna pull few things automatically
from my Azure account so in this case
I'm gonna use an existing as your app so
select existing and then click on
publish
all right if you recall these are the
very same resources that we created a
while back
you
right we have clicked on save and it's
running kind of validating the cord and
it's gonna come up within a URL now
initially the URL is not going to work
because we haven't mapped the
application to the database so that
would be the next thing
you
alright so the app has been published
and it's running from my web app as if
now it's gonna throw an error like you
see it's throwing an error that's
because we haven't mapped the app and
the DB together so let's do that
all right let's do that so let's go to a
server Explorer this is where we're
going to see our databases that we have
created now let's quickly verify that go
back to the resource group write
appropriate resource group which is
right here and here I have my database
as your simply learn database
you
all right it has some issues connecting
to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix it
you
all right so we'll have to map the
database into this application all right
so let's go to the solution explorer
click on publish and a page like this
gets shown and from here we can go to
configure
here is our a web app all right with all
its credentials let's validate the
connection number one all right and then
click on next this is my DB connection
string right which the app is going to
use to connect to my DB now if you
recall our DB was by jour simply learned
DB and that's not being shown here so
let's fix that
right so let's fix that
click on configure and here let's put
our DB servers URL not before that let's
change this to SQL Server all right
and then in here I'll put the D B's URL
so go back to your here is my DB or
servers name put that here right to
username to connect to the server that's
right here put that in and the password
to connect to the server let's put that
in
all right it's trying to connect to our
as your portal or the azure
infrastructure and here is my database
if you recall it's as your SL DB that's
the name of the database let's test the
connection connection is good click on
OK
so now it's showing up correctly as your
simple on TV that's the name of the
database that we created
now it's configured
you
all right let's modify the data
connections
you
well let's map it to the appropriate
database again all right so our name of
the database is as you're simply lon dB
and then it's going to be
SQL Server that's the data source the
year username is simply lon and the
password is what we have given in the
beginning
all right let's
the connection it's good click OK
we're all set and ready to publish our
application again now the application
knows how to connect to the database we
have educated it with the the correct
connection strings the DNS name the
username and the password for the
application to connect to the database
so which will Studios building this
project and once it is up and running
we'll be prompted with an URL to connect
and anytime we put or we give inputs to
the URL that's gonna receive the input
and save it in the database
you
all right so here is my to-do list app
and I can start creating to-do lists for
myself
all right I have the items already
listed I can create an entry and these
entries get stored in the in the
database I can create another entry you
know take the dog for a walk that's
gonna get stored I can create another
entry book tickets for scientific
exhibition
and that's gonna receive and I put that
in the database and that concludes our
session so to the session we saw how I
can use Azure services to create a web
app and connect that to the DB instance
and how those two services which are
decoupled by default which are separate
by default how I can you know use the
connection strings to make connection
between the app server and the database
and be able to create an working app I
strongly believe you enjoyed me walking
you through this session let's meet
again in another session till then bye
for now and take good care of yourself
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos standard up and get certified
click here